навичок ми проводимо круглий стіл
розвиток людського капіталу в Україні
погляд роботодавців сьогодні до
засідання нашого такого широкого
круглого столу запрошення представники
Міністерства освіти і науки представники
роботодавців представники парламенту а
також представники закладів
професійно-технічної освіти і
громадських організацій які давно з нами
співпрацюють і якраз мають на меті
покращення якості професійно-технічної
освіти і залучені якомога більшої
кількості здобувачів освіти Я з радістю
передаю слово для привітання Дмитро
Завгороднього заступнику міністра освіти
і науки України з питань цифрового
розвитку цифрових трансформацій і
цифровізації Дмитре вам слово
Дякую Ірина Всіх вітаю ради бачити
як завжди хочу почати з того що Це
дивовижно що стільки людей збираються на
те щоб дізнатися щось нове щось нове
почути всі такі складні насправді для
всіх нас часи кому я вам дуже вдячний за
те що ви долучаєтеся до цих заходів за
те що зараз нас слухаєте в записі або в
прямому ефірі хочу сказати що для нас в
Міністерстві освіти ця тема співпраці
закладів з роботодавцями є однією з
найбільш важливих ми вважаємо що це
точно топ-3 найбільших пріоритети нашої
діяльності пов'язано з профтехосвітою це
наближення наших закладів співробітників
менеджменту і студентів до потреб ринку
праці до реалії ринку праці до процесів
які відбуваються на підприємствах і так
далі ми бачимо що
це вже відбувається і в багатьох
закладах є дуже гарна комунікація І
кооперація з підприємствами і приклади
такого державного приватного партнерства
присутні в кожній області Але з іншої
сторони ми бачимо наскільки велика є
можливість потенціал для розвитку в цій
сфері оскільки насправді ринок освітніх
послуг особливо тих які надаються для
дорослих особливо тих які замовляють
підприємства він ну мабуть в 100 разів
перевищує той ринок як на якому
знаходяться заклади професійно-технічної
освіти зараз тобто потенціал для
зростання і для навчання
дорослих людей на замовлення
підприємства або там перекваліфікації
цих дорослих людей для ринку праці він
величезний і цей потенціал на жаль він
буде лише збільшуватися поширюватися
поглиблюватися через ту ситуацію яку ми
маємо зараз на ринку праці тобто
величезна міграція а також величезні
зміни в структурі ринку праці який і
зараз відбуваються і які будуть
відбуватися після війни під час
відновлення країни і так далі спричинять
величезну кількість вакансії в
підприємствах які будуть розвиватися і
величезну кількість людей які втратять
роботу або вже втратили роботу через На
жаль війну або через те що їхнє місто
було зруйноване і так далі саме для цих
людей і для тих підприємств які будуть
розвиватися ми можемо впроваджувати ті
зміни які дозволять закладам швидше і
якісніше готувати цих спеціалістів і
більш поглиблено співпрацювати з
бізнесом Що це має дати закладам
насправді не лише те що стосується
якості навчання тобто більш задоволених
роботодавців і всі такі задоволені
аплодують а насправді і це реальне
фінансування яке Цей ринок може
забезпечити для закладів освіти оскільки
задоволені роботодавці будуть
повертатися замовляти підвищення
кваліфікації своїх фахівців і будуть
хотіти співпрацювати більш поглиблено
оскільки будуть бачити фактично ефект
від цього навчання тому я дуже-дуже
радий всіх вітати на цьому заході
Сподіваюся почути багато цікавого від
наших колег партнерів і всім гарного і
продуктивного дня бажаю Дякую Дмитро
дійсно очікування багато очікувань
багато на цей тиждень тому що ми
максимально на різних рівнях
організували низку заходів для того щоб
крас мати цю платформу для комунікації
між усіма стай колдрами у сфері
професійної освіти і я із задоволенням
передаю слово для привітання пані Ользі
Коваль голові під комітету з питань
професійної професійно-технічної та
фахової перед вищої освіти комітету
Верховної Ради з питань освіти науки та
інновації
Доброго дня шановні учасники шановні
працівники закладів всі присутні
багатьох з вас Я можу назвати друзями Я
рада вас бачити сьогодні і рада з вами
спілкуватися
вже майже рік ми від того моменту коли
президентка єврокомісії оголосила рік
європейських навичок час дуже швидко
летить і ми з вами вкотре Збираємось на
всеукраїнському рівні і обговорюємо стан
нашої професійної освіти
говоримо про те що зроблено про те що
нам потрібно зробити
Головне що ми з вами спілкуємося
в якості от свого вітального слова Я б
хотіла назвати вам декілька таких
цікавих цифр нещодавно було проведене
дослідження
роботодавцями спільно із європейськими
партнерами з державною службою зай
особистості міністерством освіта рядом
інших страйхолдерів які дали нам дуже
цікаві результати стосовно роботодавців
і взаємозв'язку із системою професійної
освіти Так ці цифри свідчать що за
останні рік 30% роботодавців стикалися
із проблемами із наймом фахівців
наступна така цікава цифра що 8 із 10
професій за якими наймали працівники у
2022 році складному 2022 році це якраз
професії які готуються у закладах
професійно-технічної освіти це
Трактористи до прикладу водії
сільськогосподарської техніки оператори
котелень швачки і так далі Це всі наші
професії
ще одна така цікава цифра що приблизно
33% роботодавців мають потребу навчати
працівників і це нам ці цифри нам дають
такий своєрідний
дороговказ А що ж нам далі робити в
системі професійної освіти нам потрібно
забезпечувати нерозривний зв'язок із
роботодавцем перш за все ми повинні
встановлювати відносини на рівні
державного приватного партнерства з
роботодавцями варто зазначити що у нас
велика кількість закладів працюють із
роботодавцями і в основному із великими
підприємствами які є замовниками
фахівців у нашої системи але на жаль у
нас є Малі підприємства які не так
активно звертаються за співпрацею до
системи професійної освіти і в цьому
напрямку нам потрібно акти пропрацювати
До речі недавно з колегами Ми відвідали
Швейцарію і там є дуже цікавий досвід і
дуже цікава система співпраці якраз і
навчання за системою ідеальної освіти
в Україні ця система дуальної освіти в
нас діє але нам Також потрібно рухатися
в тому напрямку щоб її поширювати і
поглиблювати Ну я уже згадала про
Швейцарію тому наприклад я хочу сказати
такі цікаві факти до прикладу учнів
старших класів які обирають собі
напрямок навчання у системі професійної
освіти самостійно знаходять роботодавця
в якого вони будуть продовжувати
навчання в системі дуальної освіти А уже
потім роботодавець визначає заклад до
якого буде прикріплюватися цей учень для
здобуття це освітньої складовою Це
доволі цікава система над якою нам варто
подумати але ми повинні
все-таки адаптуватися до наших реалій
але досвід доволі цікавий також для нас
важливе система профорієнтації і ми уже
бачимо певні зрушення у систем
переговорів профорієнтації ми бачимо
результати ми бачимо результати
діяльності Міністерства освіти я не можу
не згадати
промокомпанію Міністерства освіти яка
особисто мені оце перша промокомпанія
яка Мені особисто дуже сподобалася Я
трішечки похвалю Міністерство але з
невеличкими можливо і нотками критики
все працює завдяки нам це дуже круто
Коли ти їдеш по центральній вулиці Києва
і ти бачиш бігборд із дівчинкою із
круасанами і ти розумієш що вранішня
кава яку ти п'єш зі сма круасаном це
завдяки
робітника робітничим професіям які
випускаються заклади заклади професійної
освіти Коли ти їдеш на своєму авто ти
розумієш завдяки кому твій автомобіль
рухається по дорозі можливо не дуже
якісні але нам теж цьому напрямку
потрібно працювати що ми більше фахівців
готували які будуть ремонтувати і робити
нам якісні дороги не турки а наші
фахівці саме українські випускники
закладів професійної освіти тому
профорієнтація дуже важлива Також я не
можу згадати про співпрацю у створенні
навчально-практичних центрів
навчально-практичний центр себе дуже
позитивно зарекомендували незалежно від
того яким чином вони створені чи то була
співпраця і з роботодавцями і вони
створювали навчально-практичний центр
заклади чи то за допомогою
організації яку ми мали і на жаль з
війною
втратили Але я маю надію і працюю з
колегами над тим щоб ми її відновили на
створення навчально-практичних центрів
закладах професійної освіти Тому що це є
саме оті сучасні хаби на яких і
базується подальший розвиток нашої
системи Ну багато зроблено за цей період
але багато роботи ще попереду
я не буду повторювати все те що зроблено
ви знаєте краще мене тому що ми робили
все це разом всі законодавчі зміни Ну і
ми не забуваємо про нас закон про
професійну освіту ви мабуть вже
втомилися я на кожній зустрічі говорю
закон про професійну освіту закон про
професійну освіту дивіться Ми не
здаємося ми рухаємося але як говорять
класики деякі цю скелю важко лупати але
ми її доб'ємо і буде в нас сучасний
закон про емоційну освіту який
задовільняє і ринок праці і роботодавців
і створює
ту сучасну систему професійної освіти до
якої Ми прагнемо що у нас вша система
професійної освіти була однією з
найкращих в Європі щоб не ми їздили в
Швейцарію дивитися як там що працює А
щоб швейцарськ приїжджали до нас і
переймали досвід у нас тому що як каже
пані Олена бачимо вона посміхається У
нас є Чому повчитися нам потрібно себе
хвалити тому що ми постійно
ухвалимо когось переймаємо досвід в
когось але забуваємо іноді про свої
здобутки У нас є багато здобутків і нам
просто потрібно їх правильно
презентувати і показувати щоб до нас
приїжджали і поляки і швейцарці і німці
і інші країни для того щоб подивитися
яка в Україні система самостійної освіти
і започали найкращі практики тому колеги
успішного і нам праці сьогодні успішного
дня продовжуємо працювати дякую
пані Ольга власне за надихаючий виступ
тому що я думаю що ми таке цю скалу
колись долупаємо рано чи пізно але
мабуть найголовніше що варто відзначити
незважаючи ні на що
маючи старий закон
працюючи над майбутнім над новим Ми
продовжуємо рухатися вперед продовжуємо
змінюватись да великий і значні перепони
і різні обставини Кові повномасштабне
вторгнення і збройна агресія Російської
Федерації але те як профтеховітяни
продовжують рухатися вперед Це дійсно
надихає і тут Варто сказати що води
наодинці наодинці рухатися дуже складно
і ще складніше мабуть відстежувати
інновації зміни в технологіях буквально
сьогодні на ефірі якраз як ми вже
сказали із столицею про в тих освіти
рівненщиною на сьогодні був в радіоефір
і
відеоролик і зараз доступні на Facebook
сторінці Можна подивитися як змінилась
профтехосвіта Львівщини і про втехосвіта
Рівненщини Сподіваюся до кінця року ми
можемо розказати так про кожну область
власне Ми сьогодні говорили про те що
цей рух він є невпинним але він
неможливий без підтримки наших
безпосередніх партнерів без підтримки
роботодавців тому що інакше вся
діяльність закладу Вона втрачає сенс
тому що ми власне працюємо дійсно на
наших клієнтів на наших здобувачів
освіти основна мета яких
працевлаштуватися
мати успішну кар'єру і наші найголовні
партнери це роботодавці це бізнес який
створюють робочі місця які створюють
запит на таких працівників і які власне
формують свою політику у сфері
кваліфікації в даному напрямку я із
задоволенням надзвичайним задоволенням
передаю слово для привітання і виступу
голови комітету зі сталого розвитку
федерації роботодавців України голові
галузевої ради Федерації Металургів
України і взагалі Великого друга вірніше
подругу подрузі професійно-технічної
освіти України пані олені колеснікові
дякую Тепер повинна повністю
перебудувати Свою промову після такої
презентації мене коли дійсно Рада вас
вітати от Оля говорила Я дійсно приємно
вражена в тим Наскільки в нас змінилася
риторика з вами за ті роки які ми з вами
працюємо Тобто ми починали Бідося
проблеми все погано все нас всіх
закриють Ну коротше був на катастрофа
Зараз ми з вами говоримо про те щоб
взагалі-то у всіх є чим чому повчитися в
нас і я вважаю це вже великий успіх
навіть не дивлячись якраз про перепони
Да в країні де немає війни де немає
таких проблем Як в нас але вони мають на
сьогодні менше ніж маємо ми і в нас
тільки що якраз Наша команда повернулася
наприклад в Фінляндія де вони були на
змаганнях
типу наших горобців Там трошки там своя
схема але подивилася і запитали скільки
то коштує Ну хто за то платить Ну і
сказали там бюджет він буде говорити про
цифри але просто висновок такий наша
представниця Лера сказала так в нас
набагато менше бюджет але ми робимо те
все самі і в нас краще ну тобто
розумієте треба дійсно цінувати що ми з
вами скільки всього зробили і
найголовніше Ми всі з вами як бізнес і
ви як закладу освіти ми розуміємо Що
найголовніше на попереду всього стоїть
людина наш студент наш майбутній
працівник і ми заради цього з вами разом
працюємо для того щоб їм стало цікавіше
вчитися цікавіше працювати в нас і я
нещодавно випадково на одной на одному
гарному заході Пане Андрію це я до вас
так реверант зроблю з асоціації
кар'єрних радників я зустріла людину яка
каже А ми от проводила дослідження серед
школярів і нас дуже здивували це
кейфаунд проводив таке дослідження
значить вони опрацьовували школярів та
студентів щодо потреби у навчанні по
Soft Skills І знаєте яке на першому
місці не затребуваючи ви планування
життя та кар'єри основи профорієнтації
53%. я до чого ми з вами неправильному
шляху якщо діти в нас зараз на перше
місце ставлять свою кар'єру то це
говорить про те що ми попереду планети
всієї нашої Тому це насправді велике
досягнення Я не знаю чи це випадково Чи
це обставина Чи це наша з вами робота ми
правильно рухались весь час немає такого
ще поки дослідження але ми рухаємося
впевнено правильним шляхом і більше того
Оля вже згадала сьогодні дослідження
нашої яке ми робили з єбр і нашими
партнерами польським фондом солідарності
центром зайнятості міністерством
освітинаком що виявилося в нас дійсно
більше 70% затребуваність саме
професійної освіти сьогодні це сьогодні
під час війни А тепер давайте з вами
заплануємо що ми десь це Буквально через
півроку я сподіваюся вже будемо забувати
про те що в нас була війна і
відбудовувати країну То наскільки
збільшиться попит на 200%. я
Тому нам треба з вами всім вибачте за
слово піднабряєшся і зробити Таким чином
такі умови дуже швидко для того щоб ми
змогли з вами ковтнути всіх тих кого
треба буде підготовити перенавчити тому
що реально відбудова нашої країни це як
не дивно це наш шанс зробити так як ні в
кого ніколи не було і ще раз повторюсь
коли ми приїжджаємо якісь різні
відрядження і дивимося заклади освіти
колеги мої Знають Я завжди бурчук ходжу
і бурчу за спиною і бурчу одну фразу А в
нас краще А нам європейські Союз то не
фінансував нам профінансували там
відповідно Наприклад якщо ми порівнюємо
з Польщею там 10% до того що
профінансував їм Євросоюз Так але успіхи
наші вони більші і краще але ми про то
якось скромно так киваємо головою і не
говоримо і через то є діти того не
бачать нам треба більше і і набагато
більше інформації про компанію згадали Я
теж скажу що я осварилася з дівчатами
казали чому я її не бачу
то дійшло до того що пані Ірина
фотографували мені борди і казала дивись
прямо по твоїй вулиці зверни увагу Я
кажу о вибачаюся так дійсно є тому
промокомпанія дуже важлива ми як бізнес
розуміємо як ніколи наскільки важливо
втримати людину в країні тому що ви Самі
знаєте скільки людей поїхало і яка в нас
ситуація скільки бізнесу в нас теж
виїхало з країни але на сьогодні ми вже
виходимо на цифри співвідношення там
вакансії і робочих місць на то що в нас
більш-менш Ми рухаємося в тому плані що
Ми зберегли багато робочих місць ми
поновлюємо робочі місця не дивлячись на
всю ситуацію не втрати територію на
постійні обстріли і ми вважаємо що наші
люди які виходять кожного дня на роботу
під обстрілами це найбільші герої в
нашій країні які не зважаючи ні на що
окрім того що виходять на роботу
продовжують навчатися в тому числі на
виробництві і Ми дуже хочемо щоб ви як
заклади в найближчому майбутньому
створювали для нас короткі програми для
дорослих тому що ми завжди з вами
зациклювались на дітях і ми завжди
забували про дорослих от Мені здається
що зараз час змін і ми як бізнес в нас є
великий запит з підготовки до дорослого
населення на коротких програмах щоб
швидко щоб ми до вас прийшли сказав
дивіться от 30 чоловік завтра починаємо
післязавтра цей гроші коли сьогодні чи
завтра ви сказали сьогодні і ми сказали
Окей поїхали і ми зробили і через місяць
ви нам випустили наприклад тих кому не
потрібно оце в нас зараз такий є з вами
виклик який ми звичайно щоб будемо
створювати умови через закон тому що ми
розуміємо що сьогодні про тих
нормативних документів при тому
навантаженні на вас і відповідальність є
яка є це Майже неможливо але з точки
зору відповідальності так само наше
дослідження показало що найбільше
затребувана від роботодавцем зараз
навичка і є відповідальність від людини
і тому насправді Як не дивно саме не
дивно я маю на увазі для вищої освіти і
Для нас це звичайно справа це якраз
підготувати ще які відповідального
працівника який розуміє що він несе
відповідальність не тільки за себе дуже
часто за своїх колег на виробництві або
за людей то що ви сьогодні говорили про
круасанс кавою А я скажу про
електроенергію наприклад Та ми всі
зрозуміли наскільки то важливо і скільки
в нас загинула людей під час виконання
Елементарно того щоб у нас було просте
світло і ми до того настільки не
звертали увагу до війни наскільки це
важливо для нас для всіх і ми забували
про те що це роблять наші робітничі
професії звичайно наші люди які працюють
які готові йти для того щоб забезпечити
нас світлом Тому я бажаю нам всім світла
Миру Перемоги пошвидше і мені здається
що ми точно з вами вже давно не
дискутуємо Куди нам рухатися ми з вами
точно розуміємо як ми то будемо робити І
тому ми з вами разом будемо якнайшвидше
Робити все щоб прийняли закон новий
закон про професійну освіту якнайшвидше
з'явилась у нас реально державна
приватне партнерство не вигляд
державного приватного партнерства а саме
як юридична нормальна форма державного
партнерства про яке нам так всі
розповідає давно І ми довго знаємо про
це теж І я вірю в то що буквально вже з
наступного року ви починаєте
сотні тисяч навчати дорослих населення і
в нас найкращі професійна освіта у світі
Я в то вірю я то буду повторювати на
кожній зустрічі на кожній країні бо я
вважаю це правильно і я вважаю що це є
правда тому що так як працюємо ми не
працюємо ніхто і будемо просити так само
як Польща інші країни гроші в Євросоюзу
Тому що їм вони багато дають А якщо нам
дадуть хоча б половину від того що їм
давали Ми зробимо з вами на свій газ
тому я в це вірю Я Нам того бажаю я вас
всіх обіймаю Бережіть себе Миру нам ще
раз повторюся Найголовніше щоб всі були
живі і здорові дякую
Дякую Пані Олено власне повертаючись до
того
якими були ваші останні слова про
реальні механізми державного приватного
партнерства і про їх нормативне
врегулювання саме можливо про це Я
сьогодні буду говорити бо
теж хочу навести таку цікаву інформацію
ми провели
позаминулого тижня і дуже дякую закладом
професійно-технічної освіти які
відгукнулися коротке таке Опитування Ти
короткий зріз
анкетування з приводу того одне з питань
було з приводу того А скільки дорослих
зараз навчаються в закладах освіти Чи
запроваджені подібні програми і Варто
сказати що така переважна більшість
закладів вони взяли участь в опитуванні
дали відповідь майже в кожному закладі
на сьогодні є подібні програми але нам
точно Є над чим працювати Тому що
переважна більшість груп які були
створені це не більше ніж 50 осіб тобто
осіб на рік ми з вами абсолютно
усвідомлюємо що це не відповідає
потребам ринку праці що
перенавчання до навчання
власне підвищення кваліфікації воно на
сьогодні стане таким головним нас немає
часу під час війни вчитися по 3-4 роки
нам треба навчатися Швидше а це означає
що треба пріорітезувати
яких саме навичок нам сьогодні не
вистачає які є найбільш затребувані і
поступово шляхом таких коротких курсів
власне набирати
повні кваліфікації або більш розширені
кваліфікації і я з вашого дозволу або
часткові або часткові погоджуюсь так
власне про те як можна підтвердити
часткові кваліфікації повні кваліфікації
шляхом неформальної освіти в нас буде ще
один спікер Голова Національного
агенства кваліфікації Але це після того
як я з вами Поділюсь деякими своїми
думками Я сьогодні кажу в нас круглий
стіл Так це не така презентація можливо
не м-м ага шановні колеги-організатори є
дуже прошу дати мені доступ до поширення
екрану Бо виходить так що я Наразі не
можу розпочати свою презентацію власне
так ось Мені би хотіли сьогодні підняти
питання власне розуміння нашого
спільного розуміння що таке Державна
приватним партнерство Які механізми
взагалі партнерства з бізнесом як ми
використовуємо трошки ми затронемо тему
дуальної освіти оскільки наразі
маємо певні проблеми
у сфері поширення дуальної освіти і мені
про це теж би хотілося поговорити разом
з вами сьогодні я нагадаю що в нас іде
пряма трансляція в YouTube І власне всі
бажаючі можуть
переглянути цю трансляцію потім в записі
також можна долучитися до коментування
під трансляцію бо всі учасники які доє
зараз в Зумі до коментування
безпосередньо під час проведення нашої
зустрічі в нашому чаті
провела такий невеличкий власне екскурсу
певні нормативні документи зокрема
європейські Оскільки ми зараз готуємося
якраз до прийняття певних правил норм
які діють в Європейському Союзі і
подивилися на форму дпп було відповідне
державне приватне партнерство та було
відповідно дослідження і тоді ще пані
Олена пам'ятає ми разом це дослідження
робили разом з Європейським фондом
освіти і Варто сказати що за ці чотири
роки з часу проведення дослідження
фактично нічого не змінилося в нас є
такі три напрямки державного приватного
партнерства
які можна узагальнити перше це створення
навчально-практичних центрів Тобто це
ресурсне забезпечення це коли компанія
фінансують або підтримують створення
відповідних лабораторій майстерень в
яких проводиться формування як учнів так
І власне дорослих здобувачів освіти де
можна організовувати короткі навчання
такі більш гнучка форма надання освітніх
послуг там де дійсно зручно і можливо
організовувати короткострокові курси і
це можна так класифікувати як ресурсне
забезпечення це навчання стажування
проходження практики на виробничої
практики на підприємствах і дуальна
освіта це власне можна вже так більш
класифікувати як ресурсну знаннєва
підтримка Тому що тут відбувається з
одного боку як підтримка у здобутті
навичок скелів так і з іншого боку все
одно навчання і стажування
супроводжується певною ресурсною
підтримкою наданням матеріалів
за допомогою яких відбувається навчання
І власне третя частина участь у розробці
змісту освіти це більше знаннями
підтримка ну це моє бачення моя
пропозиція Ми можемо з цього приводу щоб
потім посперечатися або по дискутувати
але власне ми надзвичайно Дякуємо тим
роботодавцям які активно долучаються до
участі у розробленні освітніх стандартів
на базі професійних і тут ми теж дуже
заохочуємо наших роботодавців більше
уваги приділити розробленню професійних
стандартів тому освіті після цього буде
легше гнучко реагувати на запити
роботодавців І власне це оновлення
освітніх програм врахування
регіонального компоненту або
врахування відповідних потреб того чи
іншого партнера безпосередньо
роботодавця і от повертаючись до
дуальної Іра Вибач четвертий пункт
профорієнтація Ми забули про
профорієнтацію
Олено я додам Ну дякую Дуже за коментарі
власне мені імпонує те що в нас відкрити
спілкування нагадую ми відкриті можна
задавати питання і коментувати тільки
для цього треба підняти ручку ось
Олена то не до вас вам за все власне
профорієнтація погоджуюсь пропустила
і повертаючись до того над чим ми
працювали після запуску реформи
професійно-технічної освіти це власне
було така активна і промоція і підтримка
запровадження дуальної освіти звичайно
класичну ідеальною освітою про яку
говорила пані Ольга яку ми бачили в
Швейцарії говорити на сьогодні дуже
складно тому що ця система передбачає
Коли все суспільство все суспільство всі
роботодавці
освітяни
бізнес Влада якраз всі їхні зусилля
направлені на те щоб дитина після
основної школи обирала свій майбутній
фах і йшла на працевлаштування До
підприємства і оці перші три роки роботи
на підприємстві це власне є процес
їхнього навчання держава тут виконує
функцію такої підтримки або громада
місцева підтримки це власне таке коротке
навчання у спеціальних фахових закладах
фахових школах де власне один або два
дня навчання на тиждень забезпечується і
ми поки що про таку дуальну освіту Не
мріємо але максимально все ж таки
відкриваємо двері і намагаємося
створювати можливості в нас вхід в
дуальну освіту відбувається через заклад
освіти але теж варто зауважити що
є певні переваги дуальної форми здобуття
освіти яка на сьогодні реалізована в
Україні це І власне підвищення якості і
гарантія кращої
занятості в майбутнє після завершення
такого навчання це взагалі створення
поява мотивації до навчання і до
кар'єрного зростання Ну і на нашу думку
це якраз і є оце
прекрасним прикладом посиленням ролі
роботодавців ізближення з вимогами ринку
праці
ви можете на екрані зараз побачити більш
популярні професії для здобуття
професійної освіти з дуальної формою і
варто зауважити що тут
професійно-технічна освіта була першою
тобто фахово передвищує вищого не тільки
зараз фактично фіналізують нормативне
урегулювання цієї форми Ми вже давно
працюємо маємо відповідні приклади
договорів
є і було до певного моменту часу в нас
таке активне зростання кількості учнів
які приходять на навчання з актуальною
формою освіти професії зрозуміло
зварювальне виробництво металообробка
електротехнічні технології сільського
сільського господарство легка
промисловість сфера обслуговування і
власне сфера торгівлі Тобто там де
дійсно і затребуваність професії є
велика і фахівців і попит на них і там
де роботодавці спроможні готові
розпочинати спільну закладом навчання що
передбачає
загалом дуальна форма збиття освіти в
Україні це роботодавець заклад разом
спільно працюють над формуванням змісту
освітньої програми не погоджують їх
організовують стажування в тому числі
педагогічним працівникам закладу освіти
на виробництві для того щоб кваліфікація
тих хто навчає теж відповідала потребам
і запитам ринку праці і власне беруть
участь у державній кваліфікаційній
атестації але все ж таки впровадження
дуальної освіти має низку певних
викликів і я думаю що це теж наше
завдання на майбутнє як пропрацювати ці
такі проблемні питання якщо брати
довоєнний період там умовно доковідний
період то звичайно ми розуміємо що краще
дуалка заходить для великих підприємств
тобто для малого підприємства знайти
людину яка буде додатково відволікатися
від виробничого процесу це досить
складно
декуди оскільки в нас Західна до
анального світу відбувається
через заклад освіти нам треба набрати
групу і інколи складно просто знайти
таку кількість робочих місць де ви можна
було розташувати там 25-30 учнів і це
організаційно є дуже складно виклики
звичайно вікові обмеження Ми з колегами
давно дискутуємо з цього приводу
Майже неможливо
працювати з підприємствами якщо дітям не
виповнилося ще 18 років тобто якщо
є проблеми з допуском здорового міста Ну
і відповідно є потреба у додатковому
навчанні наставників ми про це до речі
давно і активно теж останній рік з
Федерацією роботодавців України працюємо
над тим щоб запускати певні програми
навчання
[музика]
психолого-педагогічної підготовки
фахівців на підприємствах це стосується
як професійно-технічної такі вищої
освіти але мабуть найбільший виклик який
виник для нас густа в останній рік
Навіть трошки більше якщо
використовувати ще ситуацію з кавідом це
скорочення потенційних партнерів тобто
спочатку після ковіду Сфера послуг
готелі ресторани які вимушені були
просто закритися і зупинити свою
діяльність
значно зменшили кількість учнів на
навчанні натуральній освіті то після
збройної агресії після початку такої
активної і повномасштабної збірної
збройної агресії Російської Федерації
взагалі кількість компаній Великого
бізнесу і Пані Олена знає як ніхто інший
особливо металургійний вони просто
змушені були скоротити кількість
співробітників І власне зрозуміло що це
впливає на Можливості організації
дуальної освіти Тому це ці виклики з
якими ми стикаємося і ми розуміємо що
над цим треба працювати Але можливо
маючи натхнення після дійсно
ознайомлення з досвідом Швейцарії
Можливо ми тут пропонуємо інші програми
підтримки бо без підтримки дуже складно
буде бізнесу сьогодні цей бачу пані
Олену прошу я просто Хочу додати що
дійсно я просто не дуже хотіла про
проблеми але вже слайд є тому я скажу
нюанси ще окрім того що дійсно це в нас
багато підприємств залишилось на
території які є небезпечними і по
підприємствах ми розуміємо що вони зараз
зайняті допомога нашої армії тобто
виконує деякі оборонні замовлення і так
далі ми дійсно не можемо пускати дітей
тому що розуміємо кожного дня чекаємо
кожну хвилину перельоту по наших
підприємствах і тому дійсно Ми не можемо
брати зараз дітей бо це наша
відповідальність Друга проблема яка в
нас є в нас дуже сильно збідніли
підприємства зараз тому що вони працюють
вони в більшості випадків або збиткові
або близько нуля десь за окремими там
випадками Та є ті що зростають
підприємства питань нема але на жаль це
не ті підприємства які найбільше брали
професійно-технічну освіту до себе дітей
і для нас
чому я наводила приклад Європи да
Європейський союз багато там компенсує
якраз при формі дуальні чи якщо на
стажуванні Вони беруть вони компенсують
роботодавцям витрати в нашому випадку ми
не просимо щоб нам компенсували витрати
ні в кого взагалі ніколи але ми просимо
хоча б не оподатковувати коли ми беремо
дітей до себе на дуалку або на
стажування зараз виглядає таким чином що
ми повністю беремо всі витрати на себе А
ще в нас подвійно виходить оподаткування
цих дітей і тому це теж проблема Коли ми
трохи заробляли грошей воно не накладно
було Зараз коли ми майже всі збиткові
такі підприємства то звичайно що
дозволити собі ще подвійну оподаткування
коли ми беремо дітей Ну це дуже для нас
тяжко зараз тому це ще один виклик який
я би додала до до цих викликів
Дякую Олено І власне ну нез До речі
знаєте так усвідомлювати наші ризики
усвідомлювати наші виклики це теж
запорука подальшого вирішення наших
проблем про це треба говорити Ми це не
замовчуємо ми розуміємо Можна би було
зробити просто сайт з кількістю дітей
підприємстві учнів бо вони в нас є але
якраз дійсно хочеться озвучити що те що
є така проблема І тут ми
хочемо можливо потенційно розказати
більше про такі можливості і тим
бізнесом які можливо не знають тому що
маю прекрасний приклад Я його завжди
наводжу коли одне з Київських дуже
потужне комунальних підприємств
зверталося до Міністерства у зв'язку з
нестачею співробітників після того як ми
запропонували взагалі
звернутися до закладів професійної
освіти Вони сказали що вони про такі не
чули довелося робити круглий стіл
знайомство після цього заклад прикласти
на прекрасного заклади прекрасно
співпрацюють з цим підприємством
підприємство навіть запровадило групи
для дуальної форми здобуття освіти тобто
тут ми розуміємо що інколи таких
платформ комунікаційних нам не вистачає
бо кожен з нас має певну свою професійну
бульбашку як я це називаю інколи не так
просто із неї вийти і побачити все що є
додаткові можливості навколо І знову ж
таки я так трошки в теорію сьогодні
вдарилася по вивчала різні документи
якісь характеристики державного
приватного партнерства для розвитку
навичок взагалі виділяються Ну тут
мабуть те про що ми постійно говоримо
але шукаємо різні Мотиви це мотивація
учасників вдосконалювати навички і
працевлаштування це власне є головна
рушійна сила партнерства і вона часто і
про це теж До речі наші колеги
роботодавці говорять що вони ну це
виходить за рамки фінансового стимулу
тобто тут є дуже рада що з нами сьогодні
присутні представники з центру розвитку
Кор структурної соціальної
відповідальності бо це власне дійсно
більше про відповідальність і мотивація
аніж просто отримати якийсь
фінансовий Стимул чи прибуток чи
додатковий дохід
власне щоб мало бути щоб це партнерство
воно відкрите для нових учасників
тут мені імпонують наші заклади освіти
особливо будівельної сфери які знаєте не
зациклюються на якомусь одному
підприємстві Та немає там БЦ і мені
одного бізнесу вони максимально
долучають різних партнерів і показують
всі можливості і таким чином в нас
принаймні у будівельній сфері ми
отримуємо фахівців які готові працювати
з різними матеріалами з різними
компаніями
партнерство може діяти в рамках закону
наприклад про професійно-технічну освіту
а незаконну про державну приватним
партнерство його офіційний
адміністративною стороною має бути бо
може бути меморандум а не офіційний
Контракт це те про що говорила Пані Оля
і Пані Олена власне ми дійсно маємо
закон про дпп Він дуже звужує співпрацю
і на жаль не мотивує учасників такого
співробітництва
до подальшої співпраці до взагалі його
започаткування тому що процедурно
приймати партнерство На сьогодні це
такий складний контракт конкурс І як
колись зазначив пан Баланюк який скоро
доєднається в нас якось Черга з
підприємств які хочуть підписати
подібний контракт з дпп на жаль не
стоїть в Міністерстві освіти і науки
тому ми розуміємо що цей механізм він не
зовсім діє ефективним і якраз потребує
доопрацювання І власне приватний сектор
зацікавлений у якості навичок а отже
вмотивований вирішувати дефіцит і
невідповідність навичок А також проблеми
ринкової конкуренції і в цьому сенсі Я
кажу що це
ця зацікавленість і мотивація бізнесу
вона полягає не просто у відправленні на
навчанні закла освіти а в тому числі у
пропозиції інших форм тому що форми
можуть бути абсолютно різноманітними і
якщо повертатися до навчання на робочому
місці поняття Work в історії ну значно
ширше ніж просто дуальна освіта і в нас
подібні приклади є питання в тому що ми
про них можливо мало дійсно говоримо і
не завжди готові ділитися
своїм досвідом так Ага в мене все ж таки
теж є проблеми зі скілами Digital Тобто
я не завжди можу переключати презентацію
ті кроки які на мою персональну думку
назріли щодо розвитку державного
приватного партнерства в Україні перше
це розвиток правової бази державного
приватного партнерства в освіті Я поки
що говорю саме за сферу освіти і
безумовно створення
фінансових стимулів бо
це світовий досвід він доведений є певні
програми підтримки для того щоб
розвивати залучення бізнесу тому що
відверто якщо брати досвід Німеччини
Швейцарії і Швейцарії і Австрії в
дуальній освіті і в такій великій
залученості значній залученості до
навчання то
там є підтримка з держави є певні
програми це раз Ну і друге - це дійсно
велика високий рівень внутрішньої
відповідальності перед суспільством
України
на мою думку треба попрацювати над
шляхами залучення до ефективнішого
діалогу у сфері професійно-технічної
освіти і навчання
з бізнесом Я вмію інколи визнавати наші
недоліки ми дійсно не так би добре
Можливо працюємо в цьому напрямку як як
потрібно би було ініціювання дій серед
соціальних партнерів представників уряду
закладів професійно-технічної освіти і
інших відповідних учасників кращого
залучення до діалогу і партнерства це
коротко власне такі мої думки якими є
сьогодні поділилася з вами
і власне думаю що можливо багато з вас
розділяють теж подібну думку і мені
здається що якраз державну приватним
партнерство це має бути теж Одним із
таких важливих рішень і важливих питань
на які
покликана реформа професійно-технічної
освіти і майбутній закон якраз
сподіваємося ці питання врегулює колеги
нагадують нас ключових реформ система
професійно-технічної освіти
я Нагадую що ми є в прямому ефірі і всім
учасникам які сьогодні з нами в Зумі
якщо у вас виникатимуть якісь коментарі
питання Я слідкую за нашим чаком ви
можете туди їх зазначати А я
повертаючись до мого так би мовити
спойлеру і до попередньої
підведення в задоволенням хочу передати
слово
голові національного агентства
кваліфікації Юрію баланюку який сьогодні
поділиться з нами інформацією щодо
визнання інформального і неформального
навчання і таких
нововведень які з'явилися в системі
кваліфікації України як кваліфікаційні
центри і трошки Можливо ще про для
світла на розроблення професійних
стандартів Я можливо багато очікую Юрію
але я бачу у вас символіку європейського
року навичок і не можу не сказати як
насправді
Мені це дуже подобається
Юра вам слово
Дякую шановна Ірина Доброго дня шановні
колеги Я радий вас усіх бачити хочу
сказати що це прекрасно коли Ірина шумів
зазначає що вона готова визнавати
недоліки професійно-технічної освіти
тому що саме критика тільки призводить
до
підвищення якості самої системи до
відкритого діалогу до того що ми всі
разом стаємо краще і успішніше як
українська держава Ну перше я хочу
сказати що завдяки
спільній роботі Міністерство освіти
Міністерства економіки
роботодавців Та теж є тут присутня наших
дорогих парламентарів
комітету з освіти шановна Ольга Коваль І
вам особливо Дякую ми зробили
революційні речі ми
змінили принципи
формування людського капіталу і
організаційну структуру його
частині
розроблення професійних стандартів і
створили реальний попит у цій справі
тому що у нас зараз проходить 200 людей
навчання які бажають стати розробниками
професійних стандартів крім того за
останні тільки місяць я бачив два
платних курси по розроблені професійних
стандартів про що це говорить Це
говорить про те що якусь завдяки нашій
діяльності
створився нова новий
не сегмент бізнесу а а а а ота нова
форма форма інформаційна форма подачі і
продажу сервісу це надання знань
це дає можливість реально занурити
бізнес у соціальній діалог і соціальну
відповідальність в частині
формування людського капіталу тепер це
інструмент для бізнесу і Бізнес тепер
розумію що він реально в практичній
площині може формувати політику через
розроблення професійних стандартів і він
це робить успішно я вам тільки декілька
цифр скажу що є затверджено 277
професійних стандартів А заявок на
розроблення професійної стандартів є 198
це Буквально за останній рік і тенденції
до
геометричної прогресії в цих всіх питань
268 робочих груп 68 робочих груп - це
люди які можливо і витоди входите Я
просто не знаю всіх членів робочої групи
особисто хотів би познайомитися
можливо і витоди входите це 68
експертних груп які створені відповідно
до вимог порядку розроблення введення в
дію перегляду професійних депутатів які
здійснюють найважливішу справу яка не
здійснюється практично в жодній країні
Європейського Союзу тут Олена не дасть
брехати це функціональний аналіз це
оцінка європейських наших партнерів що в
цій частині розроблення
вимог до професійних кваліфікаціях саме
професійного стандарту і описі їх ми
маємо колосальній прогресії я від цього
дуже щасливий і дуже радий що я приймаю
участь у цій колосальній реформі другий
момент завдяки закону 2179 який
парламент України прийняв під час
бойових дій вже в Україні
поруч з Києвом і це відбулося в квітні
Минулого року який змінив правила гри це
означає що сьогодні немає
центрального органу виконавчої влади
який затверджує цей професійний стандарт
і перевіряє його по суті Чому він не
може і нелогічно щоб він перевіряв по
суті тому що перевірка по суті
передбачає експертних знань вмінь і
навичок людини у нас немає ні в знаку ні
в Міністерстві освіти і міністерстві і
економіки і е-е
можливо Хіба в парламенті України
експертів з усіх видів знань вмінь і
навичок які існують які зароджуються або
створюють Тому це треба віддавати
затвердження і перевірку по суті саме на
робочу гру а по формі Національне
агентство кваліфікації цю процедуру
здійснює Ну мені здається поки що такої
якоїсь там е-е шквальний критики Ми не
отримали тому
Крім того ми змінили порядок в кінці
22-го року і заклали туди обов'язково
норму наявності рівня рамки кваліфікації
А як ви знаєте Україна здійснила
порівняння національної рамки
кваліфікації європейської рамки
кваліфікації що це є це означає що ми з
Європейським Союзом з європейськими
нашими партнерами починаємо розмовляти
однією мовою це означає що не тільки 150
ми переходимо з 152 на 75 калібра ми їх
розмовляємо одна
ковими системі кваліфікації і якщо
відбудеться що процес співставлення
національної рамки кваліфікації
європейської рамки кваліфікації то це
взагалі буде прорив і наші дипломи усі
будуть визнаватися їхні і наші
взаємовизнання що це є
що ми інтегруємося через призву таких
інструментів європейських Союз Ми також
даємо чіткий сигнал для освіти бо тому
що освіта система освіти насправді вона
виконує або має виконувати може не все
так що досконало тут покритикуємо трішки
освіту
має виконувати завдання які ставить
роботодавець тому що роботодавець - це
найбільш вмотивована частина
цих людей які займаються організацією
військового капіталу тому що вона
отримує від того кошти
заробляє Ну наприклад вирішує якісь свої
проблеми в робочому на робочому місці і
все решта а освіта має
реагувати якомога швидше для того щоб
відповідати потребам ринку праці тому
якщо є ефективна наприклад взаємодії
колесникової
то тоді кваліфікаційний розрив між
потребами на робочому місці роботодавця
і тим що навчає
професійно-технічна освіта інша інший
рівень освіти встигається максимально ну
його абсолютно стерти неможливо бути
технології розвивається у нас динамічна
але це дає можливість швидкої реакції
тому мені здається що це вся справа
працює і працює ефективно наведу вам ще
декілька прикладів
кваліфікаційних центрів У нас сьогодні
вже є 25
акредитаційні справи в роботі тільки за
останній півтора місяця ми отримали 5
для акредитацій за березень травень
кредитували 6 кваліфікаційний центр 3 і
5 декларацій у нас подано по 314
постанові це в більшості прифронтова
зона там люди це роблять уряд створив
комфортні умови для того щоб після
воєнного стану пройти процедура
акредитації але зараз методом
повідомлення і декларації заявити про
таку діяльність а підтвердити професійну
кваліфікацію можна вже за 128
професійними кваліфікації про що це
говорить ринок саморегульований само
створюючий і коли мене запитують А
скільки коштує присвоєння професійної
кваліфікації ну це дуже відносне питання
тому що присвоєння професійної
кваліфікації
наприклад я не впевнений що вона мені ще
не може бо бухгалтера це робота з
нормати
вною робота з електронними системами
здачі звіту Це одні видатки
матеріально-технічні а наприклад
пристосування професійної кваліфікації
керівника
та інших податків тому е-е тому різниця
у вартості присвоєння кваліфікації є
очевидною друга річ Чи це є платною Чи
це є безкоштовною по-різному кожен
вирішує свої проблеми хтось створює на
цьому бізнес і це теж прекрасно хтось
вирішує свій кадрові проблеми за рахунок
того що він створює кваліфікаційний
центр і забезпечує свої прогалини в
робочих місцях кваліфікованими або під
людей з підтвердженою професійною
кваліфікації такі є теж практи
ки для внутрішнього їхнього застосування
для
Шановні колеги я вас дуже прошу всіх
я не то що прошу Я закликаю вас
долучатися до
армії розробників професійних стандартів
дійсно співпрацювати з всеукраїнською
об'єднаними об'єднаннями роботодавців
тут в нас є Олена Валеріївна вона вчать
може написати собі контакти
прошу вас доєднатися до армії експертів
яких у нас уже сьогодні є 210 експертів
які здійснюють акредитацію
кваліфікаційних центрів яких ви навіть в
житті фізично можливо ні разу не бачили
тільки у нас електронна комунікація це
незалежна експерти з якими агентство має
тільки цивільно-правові угоди тому
абсолютно є все прозоро все відкрито і є
через ці інструменти забезпечення якості
Мені здається що ми маємо непогані
результати чіпаємо ми так само як
критику маємо абсолютно Чи маємо ми
якісь недоліки напевно ми маємо і ми
зараз їх бачимо ми їх в процесі
вирішуємо зараз готуємо зміни до порядку
е-е До процедури акредитації
кваліфікаційних центрів ми бачимо там
якісь попереки ми це змінимо але Попри
це все цей механізм працює і тут окремо
хочу подякувати системі
професійно-технічної освіти по велика
кількість закладів
уже створила на базі своєї
кваліфікаційні центри прискорюють
професійні кваліфікації такі чином
роблять всі створюють всі умови для того
щоб у нас була армія
не тільки не тільки збройні сили були
найкращі в Європі але людський капітал
який сьогодні не не тільки після війни
буде відновити сьогодні вже люди
відновлюють Українську державу навіть
під кулями навіть під обстрілами артиле
рії відновлюють Українську Державу і
робить роблять вони все для того щоб ми
відповідали вимогам часу а були навіть
ще краще ніж очікують від нас наші
інвестори наші партнери і люди які
хочуть також підтримати Українську
державу Слава Україні
Героям слава Дякую Юру Олено бачу руку я
просто це ще хочу звернути увагу
те що зроблена сьогодні в Україні це є
унікальна модель якої ніде нема в світі
ми реально найкращий більше того ми були
найперші тому що Юра вже сказав Коли був
прийнятий закон і таке
стосовно там наприклад тих самих
часткових кваліфікація і їх
працевлаштування з ними а європейські
Союз тільки на початку цього року зробив
рекомендації для країн Євросоюзу тому ми
можемо бути попередити промось сьогодні
і під час тому я дякую Міністерство
освіти Національної гвардії і народний
депутатами які нас підтримували цей час
і ми зробили такі прориви вже з вами
просто про них так само мало хто знає і
тому я акцентую Вашу увагу вас набагато
більше Зараз з'явилося можливості в тому
числі як і в закладі
так і є І власне Можливо сьогодні буде
так трошки дивним і здаватися
незрозумілим А до чого тут освітянин І
до чого професійні стандарти І що таке
взагалі кваліфікації чого ми до них
поверталися як інколи наші колеги кажуть
А в нас як до цього було добре навіщо
нам щось змінювати Ну насправді можна
залишатися нічого не змінювати Тоді
питання де ми будемо через Я навіть не
кажу 10-20 років Я кажу через 1 2 3 роки
та і питання яке місце у світі Ми хочемо
посідати Я впевнена що в українців
велике амбіції якраз тут хочу сказати що
крім роботодавців крім
власне органів влади величезну роль у
формуванні кваліфікації А головне мабуть
воналагодженні ефективної комунікації
між роботодавцями між бізнесом і нами
освітянами я все одно більше якось до
освітянки
відношу відіграю якраз і громадянське
суспільство і хочуть задоволенням
передати слово нашому теж дуже Давньому
і постійному партнеру рада що колись в
одному із кабінетів на з Мариною
познайомили власне слово надається
голові правління громадської організації
центр розвиток корпоративної соціальної
відповідальності
Марині суприкіні У Марини є багато
цікавої інформації особливо деякі
новації які з'явилися буквально Минулого
тижня я думаю що нам всім буде
надзвичайно корисно про них дізнатися
Дякую Ірина ти так спойлеш дуже класно Я
перепрошую що я приєдналась тільки зараз
але з вами протягом всього семінару
знаходиться Андрія трощенка Андрій я
координатором кар'єрного хабу про який я
буду говорити Я вітаю вас з
івано-франківська тому що я якраз була в
потязі отже і дуже дякую і я можу
сказати Я думаю що це може трошки
нескромно але ти точно можеш це
підтвердити що центру Затока ЄСВ на
сьогодні є такою громадянської
організації яка послідовно вже постійно
вибудовує систему кар'єрного
консультування в Україні і зараз я вам
хочу розказати чим ми займаємось і теж
скажу спойлер а завтра ми будемо
презентувати результати дослідження
серед центрів кар'єри Але сьогодні я
вибрала декілька слайдів які якраз про
співпрацю між бізнесом та центрами
кар'єри тому включаю презентацію
[музика]
Я сподіваюсь ви все Бачите
Я сьогодні буду презентувати в принципі
ті проекти які ми реалізуємо за
підтримки проекту мріємо та діємо але є
декілька і наших проектів які
розпочались дуже давно і які є важливими
саме тому я назвала не тільки ми зараз
говоримо про в тех освіту Але все рівно
потрібно починати зі школи і ми навіть з
Оленою колесниковою говорили що навіть з
дитячого садочку тут я теж дуже-дуже
підтримувала
і також ми трошки поговоримо про про
навчання і про навчання Те чим ми
займаємось і одразу скажу що Минулого
тижня нас поєднала одна організація
зеленої колесніковою про що я дуже-дуже
радію ми створили асоціацію кар'єрних
консультантів і також Ми запрошуємо
людей які працюють в центрах кар'єри до
асоціації тому що ми хочемо розвивати
професійно людей які працюють в центрах
кар'єри ми це вже до дуже давно робимо і
в нас є можливо знаєте є чотири такі
дуже важливі зіркові наші проекти це
майбутнє роботи це карта професій це
розвиток центрів кар'єри і перенавчання
з державної служби зайнятості який ми
розпочали в цьому році і я хотіла би вам
розказати тому що дуже велика роль
сьогодні роботодавців Я думаю ви це
точно знаєте в перенавчанні коли ми
говоримо про майбутні роботи до початку
повномасштабного вторгнення ми провели
дослідження воно є на сьогодні ми ще
зробили дуже багато
і виставок і онлайн презентації щодо
майбутнього роботи і це було знаєте
абсолютно
новим На той період саме до початку
повномасштабного вторгнення тому що на
ці виставки приходили батьки приходили
діти і вони завжди в них одне питання
куди поступати яку професію обрати після
повномасштабного вторгнення Ми зрозуміли
що ми маємо сконцентруватись розвиватись
на відновлення України і тому що ми
зробили ми зробили додаток де на
сьогодні є саме futurex в процесі
відновлення України і тому я дуже
сподіваюсь що ви почитаєте це все є на
нашому сайті І ми виокремили 10 професій
які будуть потрібні для відновлення
України і на сьогодні ми розробляємо
онлайн на міфікацію для шкіл для того
щоб діти з цим працювали буквально
декілька таких прикладів яких це
професії на які ми сконцентрувались
після опитування експертів це
будівництво реконструкція та відбудова
зруйнованих об'єктів нерухомості та
інфраструктури тут зрозуміла і професії
це архітектор коорбаністка та монтажник
по-друге це безпека військова та
правоохоронна і тут військовий Пілот
безпілотного повітряного суддя судна та
кіберполіцейська також в нас є третій
вид - це медичні послуги охорони
здоров'я та психо екологічна допомога
потім Це агрогалузь енергетика
відновлення території та соціальний
захист сюди ми включили рятувальницю та
соціальний працівник і ми знаємо що
сьогодні в Україні не вистачає
соціальних працівників та працівниць
потім звичайно ті цифрові технології так
кібербезпека освіта та наука Ми також
включили вчителів як людей які дуже
будуть потрібні для відновлення України
та нанотехнологиня промисловість та
приватне підприємництво і транспорт та
логістика це те що ми обрали і саме ми
Прописали професію зараз розробляємо ось
цю гейміфікацію сподіваємося що це буде
дуже цікаво також наш другий такий
великий великий проект це карта професії
і я пам'ятаю як також з Оленою
колесниковою ми розробляли для Метінвест
тут твоє майбутнє в галузі металургії і
також на сьогодні в нас є запити від
укргазвидобування про те щоб
сплачувати обізнаність ті професії які
на сьогодні існують в секторі на основі
цього ми розробляємо заняття які це в
нашу концепцію виходить Кар'єрна
консультування мають викладатися в
школах з 5 по 11 клас В нас є окрема
сторінка і в нас є школи мережа шкіл
кар'єра мрії Де 150 закладів через які
ми впроваджуємо тому якщо вам цікаво то
ми також можемо поговорити в нас є вже 9
буклетів і це це є на сайті все це є
абсолютно публічно і ви можете
завантажити і викладати
Також ми працюємо з кар'єрними центрами
закладів освіти України нещодавно ми
створили такий практичний посібник як
створити кар'єрний центр Також ми вже
провели перший
тренінг для кар'єрних центрів або для
закладів освіти як його створити і ми
будемо продовжувати організовувати такі
кар'єрні центри далі тому ви можете
долучитись і
ми допоможемо вам створити такий
кар'єрний центр І зараз я хотіла би
Оскільки ми говоримо про кар'єрні центри
Я зараз хочу вам показати що нам
показала дослідження я хочу подякувати
тим центрам кар'єри і тим працівникам
центрів кар'єри які відповіли на наше
питання і тут можу сказати що
професійно-технічні закладів the best
вони дуже
класно відповіли і мені здається їх
більшість у порівнянні з закладами вищої
освіти але коли ми запитали чи
співпрацює кар'є майже з бізнесом то ви
бачите що половина не працює і мені
здається що тут є
великий
велика можливість для того щоб працювати
І щоб ми трошки зменшували ту
проблематику яка є на сьогодні що немає
людей не можемо знайти людей і так далі
Коли ми запитали як все ж таки
співпрацюють для тих хто працює Це 50%
де ми маємо це розуміти то по-перше це
запрошення фахівців фахівців до заходів
за учня до проходження практики
організація екскурсій інформації про
стажування залучення до дуальної освіти
про спонсорів бачите дуже мало але все ж
таки з того що я бачу це такі не Дуже
системні
заходи тому тут є абсолютно така Велике
Поле для роботи і дуже сподіваюсь що і
завтра коли вам буде представлена повне
дослідження тому що зможемо обговорити і
можливо навіть ІР можна зробити окрему
дискусію щодо цього можливо по групам
поговорити що ми можемо зробити на
основі
цього дослідження А коли ми запитали цю
впроваджує ваш центр кар'єри додаткові
проекти з роботодавцями то ви бачите що
тут вже більші 70% сказали що ні не
впроваджують навіть 76 хтось надав
відповідь Ну якщо не дали відповідь То
теж не впроваджують тому це якраз знову
ж таки той момент той фокус на який
потрібно звертати увагу коли ми запитали
А що ж вам не дає Ну звичайно є питання
щодо воєнного стану щодо
повномасштабного вторгнення важка
Економічна ситуація що призводить до
зменшення ділової активності закриття
підприємств брак коштів але є ще один
Фактор на який нам вказували низька
мотивація робо депутатців буде співпраці
з навчальними закладами і тут можу
сказати що ми говорили вчора з Риною А
коли якраз компанія підприємство не
знала куди піти і Ірина звичайно
направила правильне русло до
професійно-технічного закладу і тоді вже
питання вирішились тому мені здається що
ми точно можемо попрацювати з низькою
мотивацією роботодавців і можливо з і
також з професійно-технічними закладами
саме для того щоб надати більше
інформації про те як можна співпрацювати
І як це зробити більш темним Ну і наш
нещодавний проект який є ми розуміємо що
сьогодні дуже багато професій вони
опинились ну скажемо так поза бортом
щось змінюється постійно і ми розпочали
один такий пілотний проект ми подивимось
як він вийде він почався звичайно ж
будівельної сфери це оно навчальних
програм зі здобуття 4 часткових
кваліфікації там є певна частина що
Державна служба зайнятості готова
оплатити перенавчання А ми зі свого боку
готові інвестувати
ресурси проекту мрії мотодіємо в те щоб
написати такі навчальні програми спільно
з закладами професійно-технічної освіти
і також
обговорити це і це наша пряма ключове
ключове завдання обговорити з
роботодавцями Тобто Це ця програма яку
ми започатковуємо державної служби
зайнятості і окремими про технічними
закладами це буде зроблено у партнерстві
з роботодавцями тому про цей пілотний
проект ми розкажемо Я думаю в цьому році
і якщо він вийде то ми готові зробити
додаткові проекти Отже по-перше я дуже
вас запрошую завтра на презентацію
всього дослідження воно дійсно дуже
цікаво і якщо у вас є питання Якщо ви
хочете долучитись Якщо ви готові
інвестувати свої свій час та можливості
у співпраці закладами про технічної
освіти або у розбудову процес процесів
кар'єрного консультування в Україні ми
завжди до вас відкриті це наш вебсайт
можна знайти багато інформації
телеграм-канал Facebook Instagram і
Андрій також знаходиться тут Тому можна
написати і нам Андрія дрощенка або мені
або Ірині Ірина точно знає куди
передресувати І я ще раз хотіла би дуже
подякувати за партнерство Іра особисто
тобі особисто вашому Департаменту тому
що ви точно за те щоб
професійно-технічна освіта розвивалась
дякую тобі велике за це Дякую мариночку
на правду у перший раз центр кар'єри я
побачила в одному із закладів освіти
Польщі років так 15 тому назад і в мене
тоді Було таке захоплення тому що
тому що це був шок мені ну в думку на на
думку на той момент Не спадало що
взагалі щось робити з роботодавцями в
закладі освіти потрібно знаєте оця
мабуть наша філософія до 90-го року
1990 року коли заклади профтехосіти були
прям при підприємствах та вона в нас оцю
ініціативність і розуміння того що ми
тепер на ринку і в нас тепер абсолютно
інші задачі вона власне Не ставила але
останній рік він такий був дуже потужний
і на сьогодні більше ніж третина
закладів професійно-технічної освіти
центри кар'єри створили але тепер
повертаючись до того що розказувала
Марина власне нам дійсно треба
попрацювати над
підготовкою фахівців для цих центрів
кар'єрів Тобто це мають бути дійсно
фахові кар'єрні радники і змістовним
наповненням діяльності цих центрів бо
просто повісити табличку цього
недостатньо в центрі повинні бути люди і
активності які дозволять не шановні
друзі Я знаю що до нас долучився
генеральний директор класі роботодавці в
Україні Руслан Іллічов пане Руслани Якщо
вам зручно Ми би хотіли вас запросити
теж до слова бо я знаю наскільки
Федерація роботодавців не просто знаю А
ми
надзвичайно приємно з вами співпрацювати
і окремо подяка хочу сказати за те що
останні три роки робота над розробленням
освітніх стандартів у сфері
професійно-технічної освіти Вона просто
вже налагоджена в нас Ну я би сказала
ідеально тому якщо можна в нас сьогодні
тут присутні не представники закладів
професійної освіти партнери і
роботодавці хотіли би теж декілька ваших
коментарів щодо погляду роботодавців на
розвиток людського капіталу в Україні
Доброго дня мене чутно так
так чути все добре доброго дня Ну
по-перше хочу всіх привітати і багато з
вас це наші такі давні друзі Федерація
роботодавців зокрема там і пан Юрій і
Пані Ольга І дійсно В нас дуже Я вважаю
сьогоднішній система співпраці не тільки
позитивна ефективна Я вибачаюсь що не
зміг з самого початку чути там всі
попередні виступи ми зустрічалися
зокрема з делегацією Латвії там Міністр
економіки Латвії був ви посол якраз ми
спілкувалися щодо відбудову України і як
там скажімо можна поєднати зусилля там
українського бізнесу і бізнеса Латвії і
от тут якраз дуже цікава річ була тому
що Ну дійсно це не для кого не секрет що
багато сьогодні іноземних компаній і
вони бачать цю відбудовувало там нічого
як особистого як постачання
матеріалів і якісь роботи чи наприклад
там задіяності
компанії у виконанні І тут якраз у нас
була полеміка і я кажу дивіться колеги
для нас як для України дуже важливо щоб
працювали українські люди і вироблялися
українські матеріали на що мені сказали
а Чи ви готові це все виробляти Чи є у
вас така спроможність тому що ми там як
кажуть
вважаємо що чи вистачить можливості в
Україні робити Recovery Ukraine за
рахунок там власного виробництва і
власного бізнесу і отут якраз головним
нашим зараз перевагою це є незважаючи на
всю трудову міграцію все що відбувається
з цим пов'язано дійсно сьогодні наша
головна конкурентна перевага інакше
надбання національно Це дійсно людський
капітал я приведу Можливо ще один
приклад ми повернулися з Данії То були
на військових заводах які виробляють там
машини для розмінування і дивилися яким
чином їх можна дуже швидко розгорнути
виробництво в Україні десь за годину
розмови Ми там попередньо вже йшли згоду
щоб вони готові це робити А чому а тому
що в них наприклад сьогодні заробітна
зварювальника 5 тисяч євро мінімум любий
понад нормовані години дуже
високооплачувані І саме головне в них
дефіцит сьогодні людей вони не можуть
знайти робітничий професійний
спеціальності тому незважаючи ще раз
повторюю на всі проблемні моменти ми
бачимо все ж таки що людський капітал в
нас достатньо ефективний в нас є
перспектива треба лише поєднати на рівні
Скажімо так підготовки кадрів ринку
праці потреб роботодавця і відповідно і
всіх вас там ніяких професійних закладів
освіти і е-е національного агентство
кваліфікації і роботу парламенту уряду в
тому щоб ми зробили найбільш ефективну
модель Я вважаю що
Сьогодні в нас дуже багато можливостей
для того щоб Ми перебудували власну
економіку І до речі тиждень ми були в
Брюсселі і зустрічалися з усіма майже
директорами єврокомісії і всі
директорати запитували одне просте
питання Яку економіку яку промисловість
ви як українці будете створювати після
перемоги Чи ви будете залишати економіку
там сировинного напрямку чи у вас будуть
нові галузі нові технології і так далі І
сьогодні до речі і все що сьогодні ми
робимо в охоронному комплексі дав теж
оборонзамовлення це так само можливості
зробити новий нові виробництва нові
технології а це в свою чергу і нові
навички це дуже швидке навчання і дуже
швидке і гнучке скажем
перекваліфікація там робітників це
фактично ми в нас є такі випадки коли
там людей потрібно знайти за тиждень
четверта кажу є такі випадки дуже багато
машинобудування зокрема там от за
тиждень потрібно знайти сотні і всі ці
виклики вони якраз свідчать про те що в
нас що нам сьогодні ми рухаємося в цьому
напрямку Дякую завдяки вам і дійсно нам
сьогодні є про що говорити про
результати але
по-перше закликаю суспільну роботу
продовжувати а по-друге все ж таки
ну іще недостатньо наближені до потреб
які є ринку праці ще недостатньо
наближеними спільні роботі того щоб ми
могли Отакі дуже швидко сьогодні там і
якісно навчати наших працівників ще я
вважаю великі потенціал для того щоб ми
мали гнучку
зрозумілу просто і прозору систему
підвищення кваліфікації для навіть
діючих робітників і тому как бы щоб дуже
багато не забирати тема однак важлива і
я до речі завжди говорю коли ми там на
міжнародних формах виступаємо Ми кажемо
Окей
зерновий коридор - це класна штука добре
Да
рекавери Ukraine який будемо мости
дороги робити кажу Ну головне для нас це
людський капітал от людський капітал це
те майбутнє яке там ми всі як бізнес там
вже готові інвестуємо і готові дальше
більше інвестувати тут держава повинна
нам допомогти
Таким чином перше робити максимально
стимулювати розвиток виробництва
економіки всередині країни і це
справедливо і це правильно далі Коли
буде стимулювання почнеться і буде
розвиток промисловості і економіки і ми
будемо потребувати більш якісний і нові
системи там на нові навички в наших
робітників друга тоді як слід наслідок
держава повинна і стимулювати новий
механізми сьогодні робота ринку праці
підготовки робітників на наші галузі і
таким чином я вважаю там в нас
незважаючи навіть на війну вже сьогодні
ми можемо реалізувати багато перспектив
тому колеги все що Ми займаємося
сьогодні дуже важливо і найважливо тому
хочу ще раз Подякувати І побажати
співпрацю тут є і колегі мої з
роботодавці Олена Колесник або очолює
нас цей напрямок там Я знаю що ви краще
за мене може розказати про щоденну
роботу а ми як взагалі федерації
роботодавців готові підтримувати
зустрічатись активізуватись давайте
завдання тому всім ряд
Дякую пане руслане і в тому числі Дякую
за критику Ми сьогодні такі досить
самокритичні визнаємо що що йде ми як
недопрацьовуємо і надзвичайно цінно від
вас почути які напрямки ще потребують
додаткового
додаткової уваги я би сказала так і
наших зусиль і власне зараз якраз
хотілося б долучити до нашої дискусії
нашу колегу з Яскравим прикладом як
можна змінити ситуацію кардинально
оскільки зараз буде презентована
один із проектів у сфері державного
приватного протесту я би сказала що він
у нас це такий формальний єдиний
насправді І
власне коли проект починався професія
сантехніка була досить такою ультране
популярною я думаю що всі пам'ятають та
афонію І власне якісь такі асоціації
пов'язані із сантехніками ні я нінова ні
про конкурсні про що не могла йти Але
хочеться сказати так не швидко так не за
один рік але як кардинально змінюється
ситуація коли є системна робота
над формуванням знаєте я би це сказала
такої екосистеми де співпрацює бізнес
закладу освіти
влада в тому числі можна сказати навіть
ну тобто місцеве самоврядування громада
і коли ще залучаються і певним чином
громадськість то в даному випадку
утримуємося енергетичний ефект я
задоволенням передаю слово експерт з
розвитку партнерських відносин
українського Швейцарського проекту
публічно приватним партнерство для
поліпшення сантехнічної освіти в Україні
ні ні іларіонові Я сподіваюсь вона
представить якраз результати цього
проекту
колеги всім вітання щиро вдячні за
запрошення взяти участь у цьому круглому
столі насправді як зазначила Ірина на
початку своєї доповіді саме наш проект
публічно приватним партнерством для
поліпшення сантехнічної освіти в Україні
він
дійсно всі оті характеристики які ви
згадали про
публічну приватне партнерство бо вони
знайшли відображення в нашому проекті і
говорити про наші успіхи і те як ми
залучаємо бізнес до профтеха і те як ми
досягаємо свою мету щоб випускники
закладів профтехосвіти мали саме ті
знання і навички які затребувані на
ринку праці можна дуже багато але
сьогодні я хотіла би зупинитися на одній
активності на одній моделі яку ми вже
відпрацювали яка працює
є наші там помилки які Ми вже знаємо як
виправити і ми можемо поділитися цим
досвідом з усіма із закладами і з
роботодавцями і
заохочувати повторювати наш досвід якщо
в мене є дозвіл на демонстрацію крана я
демонструє кран є
чи видно презентацію
Отже яким чином наш бізнес виробники
сантехнічної та теплих технічної
продукції як наш бізнес наші
безпосередні роботодавці беруть участь у
підвищенні кваліфікації пед персоналу а
саме майстрів виробничого навчання та
викладачів
ця модель яку ми розробили вона
називається навчально-практичні
конференції для майстрів і викладачів
будучи у вищій школі і я звикла До того
що конференція що це прийшли в великий
зал поговорили і на цьому досить часто
все закінчується ми повністю перевернули
уявлення про практичну конференцію і ми
її зробили насправді практично що це
взагалі таке навчально-практична
конференція як правило вона йде 2-3 дні
Тобто це повноцінне зібрання ми збираємо
наших учасників в
Зараз на жаль тільки в Києві до цього ми
були і в Житомирі
логістичні моменти тут включаються
беруть участь всі наші майстри і
викладачі з усіх наших проектних
закладів яких є 25 на сьогодні Ми
запрошуємо від 6 до 12 компаній
виробників сантехнічної та
теплотехнічної продукції Ми запрошуємо
фахівці інсталяторів які справді знають
як працювати з цією продукцією ми
забезпечуємо абсолютно вільне
спілкування всіх учасників де вони
можуть обмінятися досвідом де вони
можуть поговорити і обов'язково особливо
зараз це безпечне місце під час ходу це
було просто велике приміщення зараз це
ви бачите на зображенні це укриття де ми
працюємо цілий день яка ідея цієї
конференції приїжджають на два-три дні
наші майстри викладачі наші компанії
виробники разом з інсталяторами готують
їм локації і Під час цієї кон емоції
перша частина коротка десь порядка 20
хвилин це теорія від наших виробників
Тобто чому саме таке обладнання чому яка
його філософія побудови яким чином саме
це обладнання забезпечує і
ергономічність і економічність
використання ресурсів після цього всі
переходять на локацію де забезпечено
практична частина де наші фахівці
інсталятори разом з нашими майстрами
разом з фахівцями від виробника
показують і пробують зробити ті чи інші
дії і таких кол кожний учасник під час
конференції отримає як я вже сказала від
6 до 12 кусочків Скажімо так теорії і
від 6 до 12 кусочків практики тобто
кожний має змогу
взяти Це в руки спробувати зробити
насправді я горжу ся тим що під час
останньої конференції їх вже було 4
Наша локація дозволила нам вирити
траншею і наші майстри працювали в
траншеї під весняним теплим плюсими
градусним дощиком у Києві
Ось так Це відбувалося бачите траншеї
наші майстри дівчата станом на зараз
понад 150 учасників вже взяли участь у
таких конференцій ми залучили до цієї
співпраці з джекона 20 компаній
цієї було проведено під час конференції
понад 50 годин теоретичних і понад 150
годин практично чому це важливо для
закладів тому що
яким чином це відноситься насправді до
освітнього процесу і до навчання
здобувачів всі теми конференції вони
дуже тісно пов'язані як з професійним
так я з освітнім стандартом які знову ж
таки обидва ці стандарти були
розроблені при дуже тісній співпраці у
дуже тісній співпраці з виробниками і з
професійними майстрами і така цифра яка
дозволяє нам гордитися тим що ми робимо
96% - це рівень задоволення
учасники поставили найвищу оцінку
Хто виграє від таких конференцій Від
такого навчання для викладачів і
майстрів в першу чергу це здобувачі якщо
подивитися на
насправді ми їх робимо на протязі
останніх двох років тому
повністю відслідкувати вплив на
працевлаштування здобувачів ще досить
важко вони ще не всі закінчили навчання
але ми бачимо що у спілкуванні з ними Ми
щойно об’їхали всю Україну ще з одною
нашою активністю це конкурс фахової
майстерності для учнів ми говоримо з
здобувачами Вони знають Куди вони підуть
працювати Вони знають де вони будуть
заробляти вони впевнені у своїх навичках
Вони точно знають що те чому як Вчать у
закладі це саме те що потрібно на
сьогодні ринку праці і не маловажно це
престижність професії саме коли в
закладі виклада
майстри показують продукцію і вміють
працювати з сучасною продукцією сучасних
компаній наші здобувачі відчувають що це
престижно це достойно І це перспективно
хто виграє від цих конференцій відграють
роботодавцем ми
це поки що попередні дані нашого
опитування про мого саме
сантехнічних роботодавців чи задоволені
рівні підготовки випускників і яких
навичок найбільше не вистачає і ми
бачимо що повністю задоволені понад 58%,
понад 50%. а технічних знань та навичок
не вистачає зазначили тільки 16%. тобто
саме технічна сторона те як наші
здобувачі вміють працювати з
обладнанням наших роботодавців
задовольняє це значною мірою і завдяки
таким конференції хтось з цього виграє
виграють так само виробники які беруть
участь у наших конференціях
забезпечується обізнані з продукцією
забезпечується правильність монтажу
правильність користування їхньої
продукції
забезпечується те що і викладачі і
майстри і здобувають ще розуміють що
працювати з якісною продукцією це
важливо Це достойно і це перспективно це
економно для кінцевого споживача саме
розуміння технології викладачами і те що
не маловажно це ми забезпечуємо
публіциті для всіх учасників цього
проекту
педперсонал яким чином це виграє Вони
отримують саме прямий контакт з
технічними фахівцями все те що вони не
знали це те що вони боялися запитатися
це те що вони не змогли отримати з
відкритих джерел інформації вони можуть
напрямок спитатися у практики
обов'язково важливо для персоналу - це
обмін досвідом побудова мережі контактів
Вони мають можливість Зателефонувати
напряму і монтажникам спитатися як це
робиться і своїм колегам і звичайно ж
таке доступ до обладнання і технології
коли мова коли ми готували ще
професійний стандарт були такі
там пункти в цьому професійному
стандарті які неможливо відтворити
інколи у закладі освіти їх потрібно
відтворювати або на підприємстві або
просто дивитися відео Ось такі
навчальній конференції вони дають
можливість доступу до нових технологій і
до тієї практики яка до того обладнання
яке його виробники Хто виграє заклади
професійти і системи
професійно-технічної освіти в цілому
по-перше це звичайно ж таке якби не
банально Це звучало це підвищення
кваліфікації перед працівників завдяки
таким конференціям ми подолали той
бар'єр що
приїжджаємо в місто і приходимо з
виробником до закладу заклад каже А що у
нас є такий виробник що в нас є такий
роботодавець а роботодавець чи виробник
каже А що в нас є система професійти ми
реально подолали цей бар'єр про
сантехніків і виробники і роботодавці
знають Вони мають прямі контакти з
бізнесом як правило після кожної
конференції ми налагоджуємо новий
контакт і новий партнер пропонує А
давайте ми дамо якесь якесь зразки
обладнання А давайте ми зробимо нові
стенди для закладів профтехові
комунікація про професію комунікація про
заклади про комунікація про саму систему
завдяки цьому підвищується престижність
профтега як правило до таких
заходів Ми все-таки запрошуємо і
центральними мас-медіа і місцеві
мас-медіа в нас декілька роликів вийшли
ICTV де було сказано і про систему
профосвіти і про конкретні заклади і про
конкретних виробників і те ще що
неможливажно на сьогодні коли мова йде
про залучення нового контентного
контингенту До закладів освіти особливо
дорослого населення коли майстри
насправді вміють якісь знають нюанси
Вони вміють монтувати сучасну
сучасне обладнання це забезпечує якась
якраз і притік і молодих здобувачів і
дорослих здобувачів які хочуть
отримувати часткові кваліфікації тобто
оця модель про яку ми знову ж таки
будемо говорити і на наступному тижні на
нашій зустрічі
так само в рамках розширення його тижня
професійно-технічної освіти Бо в ньому
більш детально
процес розказувати як це все
відбувається тому запрошуємо на
інстанфест ще другого червня
наших подальших планах звичайно ж таке
збільшення охоплення виробників 20 плюс
це мало
поширити цей досвід на іншій професії ми
абсолютно відкриті як для роботодавців
так і для закладів і обов'язково ж таки
Вже реально відслідковування впливу поки
що часу пройшло трохи мало ми можемо
зараз оперувати тільки цифрами
кількісними показниками Хто взяв участь
але саме вплив як Це вплинуло на систему
потрібно трохи більше часу але це в
наших планах тому наші контакти знову ж
таки є всі наш сайт едап.org.ua ми
відкриті ми готові до запитань до
співпраці
дякую
Дякую Ніно дійсно сьогодні ми говоримо
про різні напрямки і співпраці У різних
сферах от зеленою трошки правда тільки
торкнулись бо я знаю що ми можемо
окремий семіна робити про співпрацю з
металургійним комплексом власне зачепили
приклади
сантехнічній освіті зараз я хочу
передати ще слово на те ж нашому
постійному партнеру пані Голді
виноградський голові громадської спілки
національної галузеве партнерство в
легкій промисловості України Fashion
Globus Ukraine от Ніна вже торкнулася
питання проведення конкурсу цього року
вони зробили шалену роботу Пішовши за
принципом якщо ви ще не мали конкурс
сантехніки то ми йдемо до вас от власне
власне я точно знаю і впевнена що
конкурс який проводить Fashion Globus
Ukraine який На жаль Минулого року не
відбувся але цього року незважаючи ні на
що проводить черговий якраз доводить про
те що такі ініціативи потрібні вони
допомагають як налагодити співпрацю так
і в принципі популяризувати
професійно-технічну освіту голтовим
словом прошу Доброго дня Чим мене чутно
бак чуєте добре а Доброго дня колеги Так
звісно що легка промисловість України як
її багато інших галузей опинилася перед
викликами сьогодення це і
рело локації багатьох компаній знищення
закриття часткове закриття і от якраз та
історія з перекроюванням да Вибачте за
такий умовно кажучи наш професійний
термін коли значна кількість жінок
виїхали і багато взагалі штату
виробничого опинилися в різних абсолютно
будемо казати
різних ситуаціях виробникам потрібно
шукати де виробляти наша організація
власне стала отим координатором який
допомагає в цих нових умовах аби шукати
як себе реалізувати в іншому регіоні
дуже багато допомагаємо з'єднувати наші
заклади професійні освіти з тими
виробниками які приїхали в різні регіони
моїх між собою з роботодавцями і
відкриваємо для себе багато цікавого
насправді коли люди приїжджають
наприклад з одного регіону інший кажуть
Боже тобто тут отак от так от так от я
кажу То ви просто не працювали там себе
тому для вас здається у нас всюди класна
крута професійна освіта Отже якщо вже
пані Ірина сказала про наш конкурс да це
один із досвідів яким хотілось би
поділитися він триває вже 6 років він
досить масштабний в нас перед війною
приймала участь 66 учбових закладів із
цих регіонів України на цього року ми
вирішили що не можна зупинятися
розуміючи що треба вирішити декілька
питань по-перше
треба пояснити молоді
все добре треба пояснити молоді Що
по-перше за все професії легкої
промисловості вони є дуже актуальними
вони дуже перспективними де вони не
знаходилися А в якій частині світу
отримавши якісний освіту в нашій галузі
вони зможуть себе реалізувати і точно
дуже гідно заробити собі на життя
по-друге для багатьох потрібно знати які
закладі залишились на ринку які не
залишились Куди вони переїхати Як це
взагалі відбувається тому
це важливо для нас підкреслити третє так
само це стосується умовної переклички на
ринку виробників хто хто чим займається
в яких регіонах і в принципі Таким чином
ми вирішили зробити такий будемо казати
певний флешмоб який буде виглядати у
вигляді 24 регіональних роликів тобто в
кожному регіоні окремо буде вказана
заклади які готують саме по професіям
нашої нашої швейні перше по-друге
демонструвати їх можливості
демонструвати які вони класні Круті
наскільки вони оснащені обладнанням
демонструвати Що відбувається на ринку
виробників в цій галузі так само будуть
включення від кожного регіону по одному
з виробників які будуть передавати
вітання дякувати професійні освіті і
говорити про те що галузь жива вона
розвивається не дивлячись ні на що Ну і
Третє це звичайно звертання до молоді до
їх батьків ну і назва цього року будемо
казати тема вона на жаль така яка вона є
вилуче героїзм професійної освіти
України Тобто ми в наших прес-релізах до
місцевих змій і до всеукраїнського змій
будемо говорити
який внесок величезний внесок перемогу
вносить саме професійну освіта які
неймовірні люди вміють в ній навчаються
випускаються з неї окрім того
передбачено підняття проблематики в
кожному з регіонів де вона є
всюди вона специфічна і таким чином ми
вирішили що на Всеукраїнський рівень
виносяться якісь загальні проблеми але
там де можна вирішити залученням
місцевої преси залученням місцевих
стійколдерів десь в деяких містах будуть
відбуватися в нас і передачі і наша
зустріч якраз телебаченні Ми з радіо для
того щоб підняти актуальне питання Ну і
Отже Таким чином ми хочемо якимись таким
загальним флешмобом на різних площадках
на різних експертних
статтях залученням різних експертів
продемонструвати власне етап
розігналися на протязі майже 10 днів це
якраз буде другий половині червня
відбудеться якраз така
можна казати масована інформаційна Атака
що ви протестувати що нашу галузь жива
що в ній готується кадри що вони
перспективні До речі хотіли так само
зауважити один із приладів
нашого державного приватного партнерства
якраз була дослідження
ринку професії і визначення того щоби
монопрофесій там швачки Кривець
закрійник Звичайно це важливо Да але
десь можливо у повоєнний час вони мають
об'єднатися у інтегровану професію от
власне ви знаєте що був розроблений
професійний стандарт майстер пошиття
одягу вже закінчена створене освітній
стандарт і я сподіваюсь що з Божої
помощью і Міністерство освіти в нас
розпочнуться з вересня якраз стадіон
саме на цю інтегровану професію тому що
згідно опитування яке ми проводили серед
закладів серед роботодавців а саме
головне серед молоді Ця професія буде
користуватися
певними дуже таким зацікавленості Отже
можна довгий багато говорити скільки
всього робиться розуміє що
час важкий складний для нас важливим
знову ж таки підкреслює є функція
координаторів це як волонтерка коли
йдуть запити від наших героїв в якому
потрібно щось по нашій лінії швейній да
як в цьому допомагають заклади
професійної освіти Вони ніколи не
відмовляють це вони завжди допомагають і
ми зі свого боку готові зробити все або
допомогти їм і коли Мені іноді питають
голоду Навіщо це цим займаєшся стільки
років Ну ти ж не отримаєш за це там
гроші Да я кажу ну Ви зрозумієте ми вже
просто частина ми вже одна родина я не
можу їх кинути бо ти відчуваєш наскільки
комусь щось потрібно і наскільки вони
поруч з тобою ми так само не можемо
зараз сказати війна Ми не хочемо там
вкладати сили час гроші те щоби провести
таку масштабну компанію тому я долучаюся
як то кажуть до подяки всім всім
роботодавцям було строю хто не здається
хто не пускає руки Хто розуміє що
попереду багато роботи але це добро воно
завжди повертається і це просто
настільки відчутно Ти розумієш що країну
Перемоги і треба буде відновлювати і
Якщо зараз десь в яких регіонах А ви
знаєте пані Ірина На жаль хочу сказати
Донецька область не дає державне
замовлення і є така велика
ймовірність ще й цього року цього не
буде є проблематика в Харкові ми це
знаємо і я дуже сподіваюсь що рішення
знайдеться бо закрити заклади і сказати
що нас немає фінансування легше за все
але побудувати їх заново ви розумієте що
це буде просто неможливо тому ми маємо
шукати будь-які шляхи для того щоб цю Не
відбулось Ну і в принципі виступала
позавчора на одному із таких потужних
волонтерських форм якраз депрезентували
наш проект до мене підійшли люди які
сказали Якщо у вас є реальна пропозиція
для того щоб відновлювати певні заклади
і це не стосується державних коштів
регіональних коштів ми готові до того
підключатися як іноземні партнери бо ми
розуміємо Наскільки Ви живете цим Ми не
розуміємо наскільки це важливо так Що
пані Ірина готові до тісної співпраці і
в цьому напрямку Так дякую за запрошення
і Бажаю всім ну перш за все звичайно
найшвидшою Перемоги я по-друге щоби наша
з вами ця енергія запал досвід і він
тільки по еволюціонував по спіралі Дякую
вам дякую пані голдо дійсно ви зачепили
таку важливу тему як волонтерство
це взагалі окрема тема на яку можна
говорити
мабуть і дня буде мало ми вчора
зустрічалися зі студентами бо ми так це
цей тиждень профтах освіти зробили
такими за напрямками тобто день студента
сьогодні день роботодавців завтра буде
день педагога а Фіна працюємо ми вже
загалом професійної орієнтацію кар'єрним
консультуванням і От вчора теж те
наскільки презентували свою активну
позицію і свої волонтерські проєкти Наші
учні ну це це окрема повага
заслуговує на окрему повагу і окремі
слова великої вдячності І власне те що
на сьогодні є партнери і приватні які
готові долучатися до відбудови в тому
числі закладів освіти дійсно Луганська
Донецька область і Херсонська там є
проблеми взагалі з функціонуванням на
сьогодні мережі і ми максимально
підтримуємо їх в такій формальні чи
фактичні Скажімо так релокації десь
запуск роботи дуже все не просто але все
ж таки навіть в тих рекомендаціях які
сьогодні працюють в Міністерства освіти
і науки щодо формування мережі закладів
професійної освіти Ми в жодному разі не
виключаємо наші області які зараз
чекають від
навали зі сходу колеги
покинуть одну хвилину Я просто побачила
якраз що вийшов на зв'язок олешківський
зрадлик я просто хочу сказати що навіть
якщо якісь заклади і території зараз
знаходяться в окупації ми все рівно про
них згадуємо в роліках ми говоримо про
всіх бо ми маємо консультації з
обласними адміністраціями і це дуже-дуже
важливо говорити і щоб і ці заклади
розуміли що ми їх підтримуємо ми їх
рекламуємо ми розповідаємо от завтра в
мене виступ наприклад на день відкритих
дверей у херсонського закладу пояснюємо
взагалі батькам що онлайн-освіта це так
само якісна бо ми вже дійшли до того
рівня коли навіть в онлайні ми ці якість
можемо забезпечити тому будь ласка всі
заклади Якщо раптом працює хтось там чи
не подав заявку Це не має значення Ми
все рівно про вас говоримо Ми все рівно
вас популяризуємо підтримуємо і віримо
що ви Скоро будете разом з нами навчати
в офлайн дякую дякую Я думаю це буде
новий напрям у нас державну приватного
партнерства власне в плані відбудови і
запуску нової роботи закладів
професійної освіти олешки вітаємо вас я
вже бачу важко коментар у чатику зараз
колеги в кого ще є запитання ви перейшли
до блоку питань відповіді можна або за
допомогою піднятої руки або відповідно
певними написами дописами в чаті задати
запитання Я лише хочу сказати що
сьогодні
я вважаю що таке конструктивний в нас
Можливо ми не завершили обговорення всіх
питань всіх проблем і не дійшли до
рецепту бо наші колеги знають Пані Олено
Ми вже стільки придумували варіації як
запустити дпп в дію насправді І що з цим
зробити але те що в нас існують гарні
позитивні кейси це доводить те що цю
роботу в подальшому можна привести в
системний такий рівень і я думаю що це
будуть окремі теми для наших наступних
круглих столів Сьогодні ми хотіли
поговорити поговорити і почути
роботодавців тому що дійсно останній рік
рік війни він трошки така абстрагував на
собі до цього ми були зосереджені на
тому щоб не загубити дітей щоб
організувати онлайн навчання
згадали про роботодавців коли дійшло до
практики і зрозуміли що це новий виклик
теж з причиною війною тому що не всі
підприємства на жаль з якими ми мали
договори продовжують роботу і
шукати нові бази для практики теж було
досить складно і це питання не всюди ще
вирішено і зокрема надзвичайно гостро що
стоїть для тих не учнів які сьогодні
перебувають за кордоном колеги не бачу
піднятих рук не бачу коментарії як у
чаті знаю що є певні позитивні коментарі
на нашій на нашому YouTube каналі
трансляції сьогодні до нас долучилося
більше ніж 200 людей на початку було
майже 300 І це говорить про те що
інтерес до теми співпраці з
роботодавцями посиленні і розвитку він
залишається і ця тема є надзвичайно
актуальною а Оскільки ми маємо рік
навичок то бачу Василь Сергійович будь
ласка вам слово
Василь Сергійович мікрофончик ми вас не
чуємо увімкніть будь ласка
шановні друзі надзвичайно приємно бачити
сьогодні настільки поважне товариство
яке є небайдужим пані Ірино щиро дякую
всім хто долучився до організації такого
тижня я
Петрович директор Київського
професійного коледжу з посиленою
військовою та фізичною підготовкою буде
дуже коротким Я про нові кваліфікації Ми
розпочали роботу але прошу підтримати на
всіх рівнях введення до державного
класифікатора професій оператор
дистанційного керованих апаратів Тобто
це не тільки дрони
потім
оператор цифрових технологій виробництва
А що мене виріб від цих працівників це
три
сканування 3D друку називається це
адитивні технології виробництва а також
кіберзахист Ще раз дякую Я дуже короткий
локальний
Дякую Василь Сергійович власне Ми почули
було сьогодні питання про нові
кваліфікації нові професії виходить вони
з'являються Пані Олено
Ми почули з'являються як завжди в точку
якби яким чином вони з'являються і це ми
сьогодні зачіпали цю тему але в нас є
окрема реформа яка напряму стосується
якраз професійно-технічну освіту серед
форми класифікатора тому ми реально
підтримуємо на всіх рівнях і більш того
ми бачимо радикально як можна змінити
допомогти нам всім З вами не тільки з
точки зору появи нових кваліфікації але
забрати Назад то що належала професійній
освіті все життя вишка її в нас віджала
але ще й повернути то що ми можемо
навчати то що зараз забрали в нас вищу
освіту тому ми працюємо над тим ми Я
думаю що все зробимо і звичайно щоб
найближчий час бо я відкрию маленький
секрет У нас вже є велика підтримка
стосовно цієї реформи і навіть ми почали
вже знаходити гроші на ту реформу для
того щоб її реалізувати Я дуже вірю що
вже в наступному році в нас буде новий
класифікатор
ми направили відповідні листи вони вже
знаходяться в національній поліції Але ж
ви розумієте що є функції які нам не
притаманні Я тут не можу зараз про це
говорити тому що можемо я ми вас з Юрою
баланюков навчимо Як це можна зробити
навіть без а з Юрієм баланюком Ми також
розмовляли на цю тему я його бачив зараз
не помічаю Я сподіваюсь що він мене чує
ми все зробимо Спасибі Спасибі Василь
Сергійович Тут ви маєте нашу підтримку
поруч зі мною Сергій Петрович Коваленко
будь ласка до нього де застрягло ми
підтримуємо 100%. я бачу в нас є на
Ютубі було запитання
від Львівської політехніки від
національного університету Це скоріше за
все на запитання пані Олена Я вам просто
озвучую зацікавлені у співпраці у
напрямку Металургів Я думаю що ми окремо
я відповім одразу щоб в записі були ми
отримали листа ми готуємо відповідь на
жаль
відповіді не очі коли ми металурги а не
ювеліри окей добре але я хочу сказати що
в нас є і ювеліри зокрема прекрасне
училище в місті Києві Ми готові
співпрацювати спільно так бачу пані
Тетяна стойчик передаю слово землякам
Доброго дня шановні колеги Дуже щиро
хочу подякувати саме директорат
професійно-технічної освіти за те що ми
маємо таку можливість як заклади
професійної освіти
отримувати саме такий позитивний досвід
співпраці роботодавців і закладів
професійно-технічної освіти у різних
галузях економіки це для нас дуже
важливо в регіонах і в мене власне Не
питання а подяка тому що я зараз маю
таку підтримку таку платформу саме олені
колесникові яка представляє сьогодні
саме групу метінвестів які незважаючи на
те що зараз іде війна
співпрацюють ті закладом
професійно-технічної освіти саме в
рамках актуальної підготовки і сьогодні
закладу саме 48 осіб дійсно оплачуваних
робочих місцях це на центральних
сплачено
гірнича збагачено комбінацію і
центральному генічому збагачено комбінат
тому ми вам Дякуємо що ми розуміємо що
підприємство працюють на 70% від
загальної потужності але це такий
позитивний процес на 15 а подекуди на
нулі ну я говорю про тих пройти
підприємства які з якими Ми співпрацюємо
наразі зараз і що незважаючи на такі
виклики які є сьогодні в нас в Україні
все ж таки підприємство знаходиться
можливість ці співпрацює закладом мені
ще раз подяка це є такий дійсно супер
позитивний досвід в організації
ідеальної підготовки Дякую Ну а власне
хочу теж сказати в свою чергу
гірничо-технологічний ліцей були одні з
піонерів які запроваджували дійсно дуже
позитивно досвід дуальної освіти але
варто тут зазначити дійсно без своїх
партнерів роботодавців там найвищі
зарплати у вас тоді були коли ми
оцінювали
навчання що були ми насправді незважаючи
цю ситуацію Ми намагаємося отримати тому
що ми робимо на руці ми постійно робимо
звіт про аналітичний звіт кожного місяця
раз квартали раз на півроку по саме по
скільки людей в нас залишається яка
заробітна плата і так далі я бачу що ми
реально досі тримаємо ту планку
незважаючи на то скільки ми втратили і
втрачаємо кожного дня тому ми розуміємо
Точно Що найголовніше в житті - це наше
люди
Так дякую а Кривий Ріг стоїть Я знаю там
живуть не знаю чи тільки корів гуляю теж
залізні люди взагалі до нас важко
дібратися тому що у нас є кар'єра які
нас захищають
Це точно дякую пані Тетяна
начебто начебто ми на всі питання
відповіли Ми перебрали з часом я одразу
Перепрошую наших колег начебто йшли всі
за часом а потім трошки
додалися запитання і коментарі друзі Ви
знаєте що ми абсолютно відкриті можна
залишати коментарі можна писати на
адресу директорату наших колег-партнерів
Федерації роботодавців І власне всіх
сьогодні пані Ользі точно знаю що вона
відповідає коли їй пишуть і я сподіваюся
що це наша не остання зустріч в нас ще є
дійсно чим поділитися І про що
поговорити очікується для заходів в тому
числі у червні місяці
частина з них буде в такому змішаному
форматі і онлайн в тому числі а зараз
хочу сказати що в коментарях під нашим
відео в Ютубі Ви маєте посилання на ще
один захід який відбудеться сьогодні а
це дійсно Ми пояснюємо з національним
агенством кваліфікацій що таке
професійні стандарти Навіщо нам потрібно
взагалі про них думати і говорити і як
переходити в подальшому на створення
акредитації кваліфікаційних центрів там
буде більш така глибока
інформаційна якраз така активність від
національного агентства кваліфікації
більше того Андрія трощенко вже теж
розмістив в нашому чаті інформацію і
Link на посилання для тих хто бажає
долучитися з питань
презентації наших результатів по
центрам кар'єри і на воркшоп відповідний
по розвитку центрів кар'єри ми дійсно
сподіваємось на подальшу підтримку наших
партнерів і на нових партнерів і на ще
більший розвиток активності є всім
надзвичайно Дякую за сьогодні долучився
до нас
бажаю вам у нас Екватор там Ми якраз
прийшли до Екватора тижня професійної
освіти вважаю всім такої ж цікавої
другої частини тижня і до нових
зустрічей рада всіх бачити Слава Україні
Героям слава миру та Перемоги